if you may remember last time we did an
example question and it was by gentle
introduction into projectile motion
I carry had a look at a situation and it
started off very similar to this you
know we had something that was being
projected at a particular speed right we
thought about gravity and the effect
that it would have on our time equations
and then we said we'll look this you
know this entire it sitcom okay now what
we were doing last time was that we
comprehensively defined I think it was
like two adamance T I think it was Adam
Stephen the Apple wasn't it yeah we said
look this is where they are this is how
they throw and then we ask the whole
series of questions like how long does
it go for how high does it go things
like that but far more common will be
things like this where there are
conditions that are known about the
beginning but what they want is an
outcome and you have to decide what will
be the initial conditions that will
bring about that outcome okay so if I
have you know a candle or something like
that
it'll project objects at this speed and
I'm trying to hit something this far
away my question is well my first of
many is where do I aim this thing
what angle should I give it so that it
will actually hit the target okay so
this is our setup I want to ask three
questions of it and that was the first
one question one where do I am okay I
want to hit this target wish that point
they can whatever okay question two is
that something we call flight time
flight time which means how long is that
projectile how long will it be in the
air assuming that I fire it in the right
direction and it does hit the target
okay
and lastly I want to know some
information about when it actually hits
right specifically I want to know how
hard hits and at what angle
question mark okay so simple setup I
have an unknown right getting that
unknown is my first question where do I
points okay okay how long is it in the
air what's it gonna all look like when
it actually hits okay so the direct our
mission we've done a couple lessons on
this already where do I begin
what's my starting point for every
projectile motion question okay this is
a clue isn't it right I've got some
conditions that are gonna be the same
for all my questions one for X and one
for y right I'll get to the Y's in a
second let's do all the x's what's the
horizontal acceleration it gets
projected and there's nothing pushing it
forward or pushing backward okay now if
I want to go further than this right
next time what do I have to do I have to
integrate right and so I'm gonna get
some kind of constant okay how do I
evaluate that constant I need some kind
of initial conditions don't I so in fact
what you've noticed is that even though
this is where were you going to start
out working right there's other piece of
information that I have to tease out of
here which I don't know yet
okay so in addition to this what I'm
going to do and I'm gonna need some more
space for this is I need to resolve the
initial velocity remember what resolving
velocity is about what's that about your
silence is reassuring resolving velocity
is it that a key a speed and a direction
and turning into something horizontal
and something very cool okay so you draw
a diagram right enjoy this guy okay what
information shall I put on you it is
your speed okay so he's being projected
like so right when is the initial speed
ball ball on this diagram
it's the hypotenuse isn't it there's my
200 okay we're at X dot y dot on this
diagram the X dot is horizontal right
now I'm going to figure out what it is
in a second and Y dot is vertical good
what else am I missing
ah there's an angle here I don't know
what it is
but that's where it is okay I don't know
what it is don't know where it is okay
so therefore on the basis of this
diagram what can I say about next door
and why don't
mmm this is right angled right so I can
do some writing we're trying to trick
here yes for instance I could say cos
alpha adjacent and hypotenuse that's X
dot on 200 yes so now I've got my
expression for X dot see that okay so
there's my horizontal velocity in
exactly the same way same argument I can
say why don't we 200 sine alpha you can
see where I get that from country okay
so great now I've resolved this out okay
this is when time equals zero
this is resolving initial velocity okay
great now that I've done that I can come
back over and say okay now I can
evaluate this constant why don't we get
when time equals zero right this is a
time equation right X dot is this right
so it's just going to be that's that's
the constant 200 cos alpha alpha is some
kind of constant which I decide at the
beginning it doesn't change as I go
through right so there you go
acceleration velocity integrate again
now just by convention they put the T
there and he only suggest me why that's
probably a good place to put it even
though on the end might have been a more
natural place to put it yeah yeah you
don't you don't want to confuse the
variables well that's not even a
variable but you get the idea you don't
want cos alpha/2 it's not cos alpha t
right the T is separate there's another
constant of course okay now at the
beginning right we said look we're
firing this from some point we don't
even have a picture for this year right
what would this look like hmm something
like this okay and he's gonna hit
something two kilometers oh wait okay so
we can actually decide where we want
this um this firing point to be okay and
some values will obviously make more
sense than others what do you think we
should call this how about the origin I
think that's a good call it'll make our
numbers nice in there neat okay so you
can see what I did to get rid of this
constant I put in initial horizontal
bottom right to get rid of this constant
I will put in initial position see
what's going on okay
so X is going to be equal to just this
done okay so far so good let's do all
the vertical stuff which is far more
interesting okay
I'm gonna put it
okay acceleration you got gravity and
that's it right so what's my
acceleration equation for y negative 10
because it's going that way okay so you
integrate the once and third concert
would be okay how do I get rid of this
constant again initial which one I've
got a lot of initial conditions team
you just saw your random phrases Tarina
I want the initial vertical velocity
right that's what's gonna resolve this
coin so you get this sorry there's my
integration minus 10 T when T equals
zero you're just gonna get this sign
character yeah 200 alpha cool okay at
this point I integrate one more time and
this would give me very cool
displacement minus 5 T squared which you
see a what off right there's this guy
again and my fourth and final constant
involvement okay how do I get rid of
this one how do I get rid of this one it
was initial position right but this time
it'll be initial vertical position which
is also zero okay cool
now we've got our equations set up in
time done now hold on
what was I trying to do what was the
point of setting up all of these
equations where am I going
I want to know an angle I want to solve
this guy right but specifically I want
the angle that will hit this right angle
hit this okay so if I have this in sort
of a let me put this guy back if I have
him in a coordinate system right and I
started at zero zero what might be a
sensible thing to call the position of
the target
to zero okay now I'm gonna stop there
for a second because I think we there's
a better like to zeroes lot bad thing to
call it but I think there's a better
option have a look at all the
information we've been given which is
not all that much really probably now I
have a choice I've got meters an hour
kilometers right so I can either turn
this into point two kilometers per
second or I can turn that into two
thousand meters I think I'm gonna turn
this into two thousand meters okay they
go okay so what I want to do is I want
to know what values the time and alpha
are going to get me there okay that make
sense